[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieses bild kennt man von den
österreichischen autobahnen was man
allerdings nicht kennt ist ein
truppentransporter unimog denn genauso
heißt dieses fahrzeug auf dem ich hier
sitze außer dem planeten ist gewohnt mal
segelboot mit meinem partner zu teilen
hier im unimog hingegen haben bis zu 16
leute platz also acht auf jeder seite
[Musik]
mainz rpo zu steuern braucht man schon
sehr viel gefühl
vielleicht braucht man nicht ganz so
viel für den unimog man muss aber
trotzdem sehr geübt sein
vor allem in der lts haltung das
bedeutet er hat acht vorwärts und sechs
rückwärts gänge
[Musik]
der unimog mit 11,5 tonnen und 177 ps
das wirklich besondere daran ist
allerdings dass man den ausbau ganz
schnell wechseln kann
[Musik]
der unimog ist also nicht nur das
geländegängige lkw verwendbar sondern
auch ein sanitätsfahrzeug und mobile
werkstatt und deswegen ist er besonders
für den einsatz im krisengebiet geeignet
[Musik]